Speaker 1: I am so glad to have the opportunity
today to, I guess, bring you more evidence
that my instinct yesterday, when we looked
at clips of Donald Trump's former attorney
general William Barr, saying Trump's election
lies were B.S. and whatever.
It doesn't make Barr a good guy.
It doesn't even make him a sensible guy.
And the day after these clips went viral of
William Barr saying Trump brought in a clown
show of lawyers after the election, all of
this stuff.
When pressed, William Barr still says I'd
vote for Trump over a Democrat if he ran in
2024.
This is exactly what I was talking about yesterday.
Bill Barr after saying Trump lied about the
election.
He incited the attack on January 6th, et cetera,
et cetera.
He told Savannah Guthrie yesterday, Well,
if it's Trump versus a Democrat, of course
I'm going to vote for Trump because Democrats
are really, really bad.
This is why I say these are not good people.
These people are not our friends or any of
it.
Bill Barr wants to sell books.
That's all that's going on.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: You say in your book, it's time
for the party to move on from Trump.
Liz Cheney has said he is not fit to serve
and should not be ever near the Oval Office
again.
Speaker 3: Do you agree with that?
Well, I certainly have made it clear I don't
think he should be our nominee, and I'm going
to, you know, support somebody else for the
nominee.
But if he is the nominee and you have your
choice, is Donald Trump or whoever is running
on the Democratic side, would you vote for
him?
Because I believe that the greatest threat
to the country is the progressive agenda being
pushed by the Democratic Party.
It's inconceivable to me that I wouldn't vote
for the Republican.
A nominee so favorite, if he lied about the
election and threatened democracy, as you
write in your book.
Well, it's better than a Democrat.
It's hard to project what the facts are going
to turn out to be three years hence.
But as of now, it's hard for me to concede
that I wouldn't vote for the report,
Speaker 1: even though he's a threat to democracy.
A threat to our country incited a riot, lied
about who won the election.
Brought out a clown show of lawyers.
I mean, listen, progressives are really the
threat.
This is why these people are so dangerous,
guys.
And this is why I told you he stumbled across
some small factoid, some small element of
truth.
But this is not a this is not a good guy.
And it's the same thing with Liz Cheney.
At the end of the day, Liz Cheney maybe wouldn't
vote for Trump against a Democratic nominee,
but she still did vote with Trump, something
like 88 percent of the time when Trump was
president.
Just as a reminder, here's what William Barr
said about Trump yesterday.
But remember, he'd still vote for Trump over
a Democrat,
Speaker 3: and I told him that all this stuff
was bull and about election fraud.
And you know, it's wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was, and he started asking
me about different theories and I had the
answers.
I was able to tell them, This is wrong because
of this, you're trying to set him straight.
Yes.
And you know, he listened.
He he he was obviously getting very angry
about this.
I said, OK, well, look, I understand you're
upset with me and I'm perfectly happy to tender
my resignation.
And then, Oh, you slept to the desk and he
slapped the desk and he said, accepted.
Accept it and then boom, he slapped it again.
Accept it.
Go home.
Don't go back to your office.
Speaker 1: So William Barr saying that William
Barr also referring to all those wacky lawyers
that Trump hired to try to flip the election
as a clown show
Speaker 3: and about election fraud.
And you know, it was wrong to be shoveling
it out the way his team was.
And then he also
Speaker 4: told Trump what he thought of his
legal team.
Not a lot.
Speaker 3: I said the reason you are where
you are is because you wheeled out a clown
show of lawyers, a clown show.
Yeah, clown car or something like that.
I said, Yeah.
Speaker 1: So anyway, he'd still vote for
Trump if there's a Democrat.
I mean, he says, this guy is not fit to serve.
He's a threat to the country.
Terrible for democracy.
All this stuff.
Well, but now I mean, listen, I'm not going
to vote for Joe Biden completely, you know,
innocuous milquetoast Democrat who, you know,
will be lucky to have major accomplishments
that that change American society or the economy
in any serious way.
It's actually almost worse that, you know,
there's the people who think Trump's great
like, OK, well, I disagree with you.
And I would I would have that argument with
you.
But these people realize Trump is not a threat
to democracy.
Unfit to serve.
And they still say, Well, if it's Joe Biden
or Carmel, I mean, I just can't imagine I
would ever vote for a Democrat.
It's completely and totally bonkers.
And this is exactly what I was talking about
when I was saying, this guy wants to sell
a book.
That's all he wants to do.
Send me your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at De Packman.
The David Pakman Show depends on your support
to do what we do.
You can sign up on our website.
Join Packman dot com, get a membership, you'll
get the Daily Bonus Show, as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show.
And you'll get the show every day, not only
without commercials.
You'll get it five to six hours before everybody
else.
There's some really great perks to being a
member, and you can sign up at join Packman
dot com.
Also want to mention we have a new initiative.
If you were already a content creator, we
are going to be doing a sort of group coaching
thing where I will work with four or five
handpicked content creators to help grow your
platform.
The only requirement is you must already be
regularly creating content on one of the major
platforms, and you have to apply at David
Pakman dot com slash coaching.
I mentioned yesterday four or five times David
A bunch of people emailed me saying, David,
I'd like to apply.
Do not email me.
If you email it, it's going, I hate to say
it, the instructor.
By virtue of not being able to follow the
instructions, it's already bad.
OK, David Pakman dot com slash coaching.
No need to email if you're interested.
David Pakman dot com slash coaching and the
information is there, you can apply.
It's going to be a cool new thing hoping to
grow some other content creators?